un lundi porteur d'espoir dans les rues
de la capitale
un mois après le 3e confinement imposée
par le gouvernement pour lutter contre
la propagation du colis de 19 le pays
entame une nouvelle phase de
déconfinement pas de levée complète des
restrictions annoncées à ce jour mais
une sortie de crise espéré est envisagée
en quatre étapes
ce lundi les déplacements inter
régionaux en france sont de nouveau
autorisées et il n'est plus nécessaire
de présenter une attestation pour les
déplacements en journée les cours en
présentiel reprennent dès ce jour pour
les collégiens et lycéens mais le nombre
d'élèves par classe restent limités et
si le couvre feu est maintenu le
gouvernement nous gratifie tout de même
d'une nouvelle attestation indispensable
pour les déplacements compris entre 19
heures et 6 heures du matin il faudra
donc attendre jusqu'au 19 mai pour
profiter plus longuement des soirées
c'est en effet à cette date que marquera
le début de la deuxième étape du
déconfinement avec des changements plus
importante cette fois le gouvernement
prévoit de décaler le couvre-feu à 21h
les magasins pourront rouvrir tout comme
les terrasses des restaurants restées
closes depuis le début du décret du 29
octobre 2020 les lieux culturels que
sont les cinémas les théâtres ou encore
les musées seront eux aussi autorisé à
rouvrir à condition de respecter les
protocoles sanitaires réouverture
également des établissements sportifs
pour les spectateurs avec une limite de
800 personnes en intérieur et 1000 en
extérieur autre changement majeur à
partir de cette date la reprise de
certaines activités sportives couvertes
et en plein air dans le respect des
protocoles sanitaires
si le couvre-feu est raccourcie de
quelques heures il sera autorisé à
partir du 19 mai ne se réunir non pas à
6 mai à 10 personnes
la troisième étape du déconfinement aura
lieu le 9 juin prochain le couvre-feu
sera alors décalé à 23h les salles des
cafés des restaurants succéderont aux
terrasses et pourront ouvrir en
acceptant maximum six personnes par
table jusqu'à 5000 personnes pourront se
réunir dans des lieux accueillant du
public et la pratique d'activités
sportives s'élargira aux sports de
contact autre changement important
l'accueil de touristes étrangers
présentant un pass sanitaires à savoir
un test pcr ou une attestation de
vaccination enfin la quatrième et
dernière date de ce calendrier à savoir
le 30 juin
un 2021 marquera l'étape la plus
importante de ceux des confinement sans
pour autant signifier un retour complet
à la vie normale
cette fois le couvre-feu ne sera plus en
vigueur et en possession d'un pass
sanitaires il sera autorisé de
participer à tout type d'événement
réunissant plus de 1000 personnes
malgré ces nombreux changements
réjouissant tous seront cependant soumis
à l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
et il n'est pas exclu de voir ces
mesures s'adapter en fonction de la
situation dans les territoires
grande absente de ces nouvelles mesures
les discothèques qui restent fermés
jusqu'à nouvel ordre